all right did we ask for Glover and
Randolph over here what are we in
trouble you are should you be in trouble
yeah reporting personal we sure yeah
how bad that I read all right
congratulations
sure
crazy nuts all day you can't take your
picture page of the selfie you know I
take a cell phone okay
they would you men take
official
it can be a real nightmare all day long
every day everywhere man uh-huh see
pictures pictures I'm not complaining
because I love it I wouldn't trade it in
nobody would but here's something that
can make me very very happy
if you see me in public
right I mean being that you're somebody
who's watching my second channel right
that's you guys are real ones you guys
are the ones I want to meet you guys are
the ones I I love so much that's why I
do this man so if you see me it's gonna
be a little code word kind of a thing
right so they're like I won't be
frustrated at all come up to me and say
it's the age of the selfie don't mind if
I do it should it be is the age of the
selfie hey I take your pic I don't care
you saw me it's the age of the selfie er
than whatever you what I don't care
that's the code word if I hear that I'll
I'll be so happy I'll get a big hug I'll
say man I Courtney Love the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of you whoops while there's still
some Kevin Spacey of there
coolest thing about American Airlines
find out the cure and cheese
yeah
it
rest now my child you've had a long
weekend
yeah
if you want to make me really happy tell
me it's the age of the selfie dude and I
got your hat and your shirt and your
autographed New York Times best seller
online click here and get it and
subscribe to my second channel
you